[Music]
the wearable fitness tracking market is
booming we are all buying but are we
benefiting from them when it comes to
sustaining motivation and achieving our
goals are they actually helping we want
to know we want to know if tapping into
the power of social network is actually
helping us achieve goal success our
research actually shows that most of us
are giving up on our gadgets at the very
moment that they can help us the most
the good news is that there is a way to
push through at this critical moment and
the lesson we learned here can be
applied to many goals we value in life
way beyond working out at our gym here
is what we found
gadgets like Fitbit and websites like
stick K comm give us abundant access to
social information as a metric VP feet
users check their social posts more than
600 48 million times within 5 months of
its launch although people are
enthusiastic to check social information
see how well our friends are doing with
their Fitbit our passion does not last
research showed that one third of our
customers actually abandoned their
wearables within six months of purchase
we call this social information
avoidance when we have easy access to
information about other people working
on their goals but we choose to avoid it
our research shows that people are the
most likely to avoid social information
when they're halfway under goal
compared to when they're just starting
or when they're about to finish for
example we found that people who are
playing a Wii bowling game when they are
halfway through their game there are the
most reluctant to actually turn their
head and see how other players are doing
on their bowling games so why is this
important this is important because when
we are halfway through our goal that is
the moment that the social information
can help us the most that is the moment
to actually pick up our Fitbit and see
how well our friends are doing because
whether we find out that other people
are doing better than us or worse than
us we will now have an anchor to
motivate us to work harder on our goals
so the next time you feel demotivated
maybe a lack of momentum you feel like
giving up check your Fitbit log back
into your online support group or maybe
just look around you talk to the
students sitting next to you in the
class
social information is incredibly
valuable by leveraging social
information at the moment we needed the
most we can all have a better shot at
achieving our success